Transcriber: Fadia ElMoubarak
المدقّق: Alsa Saal
(تصفيق)
أنا متأكد بأن الأغلبية قد سمعت عن مصطلح
يتكرر كثيراً في السنوات الأخيرة،
وهو ما يسمى بالثورة الصناعية الرابعة،
لقد بدأت تتداخل في أغلب المجالات
المستقبلية،
(صورة)
في مجالات ثورة المستقبل وصناعة المستقبل،
تعتبر من أهم سمات هذه الثورة
(صورة)
ما يسمى بالتحول الرقمي،
التحول من الجيل التقني الذي قمنا بالتعود
عليه خلال السنوات الأخيرة،
الى جيل أكثر ذكاءاً وأكثر تواصلاً وأكثر
تفاعلاً،
من خلال الترابط والتداخل والتفاعل ما بين
جميع المكونات في المحيط حولنا،
وأيضاً تفاعلها مع البشر،
كل شيء حولنا في المستقبل القريب ضمن نطاق
الثورة الصناعية الرابعة
سوف يكون تحت مظلة ما يسمى ب
"انترنت الأشياء"
كل شيء متصل بكل شيء.
في المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي الذي حمل نفس
المسمى "الثورة الصناعية الرابعة"
(صورة)
وكتاب "كلاوس شواب" الذي حمل أيضاً نفس
المسمى،
والذي أشار بعمق وبوضوح به أنه لا يحتمل
اطلاقاً أي تفاعل خارج نطاق مكونات
الثورة الصناعية الرابعة، ألا وهو النقطة
المركزية،
والأهم من ذلك على الاطلاق هو وجود الذكاء
الاصطناعي
كمكون رئيسي من مكونات تقنيات المستقبل.
لنأخذ مثال ونتدرج به خطوة بخطوة لنستطيع أن
نفهم ما الذي يحصل في المستقبل القريب
أو البعيد،
في البداية لنأخذ سيري من أبل أو مساعد
غوغل أو أليكسا،
نحن نتفاعل معه كأنه عقل بشري يفهم ويدرك ما
هو الكلام الذي نتكلمه
حتى لو كان كلاماً صوتياً محكياً،
ولكنه استطاع بعقل اصطناعي أن يفهم هذا
الكلام ويحوله لمادة مفهومة ويتخذ قرارات
ويتفاعل أيضاً مع الخارج،
وفي النهاية يستطيع أن يجيب بمادة صوتية
مسموعة،
وكأنه فعلاً إنسان يتفاعل معنا بدرجة عالية
جداً من الذكاء وبدرجة عالية جداً من الدقة،
ولكن ماذا لو تطورت الأمور قليلاً أكثر الى
الأمام
وأنتجنا ساعة ذكية مرتبطة بجسدك قادرة
على أن تقرأ معظم تفاعلات جسمك الحيوية،
وعند توقع هذه الساعة الذكية لحدوث خلل في
صحتك ستتواصل مع أقرب مستشفى
ويقوم المستشفى بشكل تلقائي بحجز موعد لك،
أو تقوم بإرسال سيارة إسعاف لك
بشكل ذاتي بدون أدنى تدخل منك،
ولكن ماذا لو تطور الأمر بشكل أكبر الى ما
يسمى بالبيوت الذكية،
من الممكن أن تقوم بالتنبأ باقترابك من
منزلك وتحاول من خلال أجهزة إشعار خارجية
أن تقوم بقياس درجة حرارة الخارج، وأجهزة
إشعار داخلية تقوم بقياس درجة حرارة الداخل
لتقوم بتحضير التكييف الهوائي لك بأفضل درجة
حرارة ممكنة لتتوافق مع احتياجك الشخصي،
أو تقوم بتشغيل سخان المياه لك أو تحضر
آلة القهوة لك،
ولكن ماذا لو تطور الأمر ليتفاعل هذا
البيت الذكي مع الداخل والخارج
من خلال مثال ثلاجة ذكية يوجد بها مجسات
استشعار أو آلة تصوير
قادرة أن تتنبأ بعدد حبات البيض الموجودة
داخل الثلاجة،
وتعرف وتتنبأ بأن عدد حبات البيض الموجود لن
يكفيك الى نهاية الأسبوع
وتقوم باصدار أمر لأقرب متجر موجود نسباً
للمنزل فيقوم هذا المتجر بإعداد هذا الطلب
ويقوم بإيصاله لمنزلك، ويخصم قيمة هذا الطلب
من حسابك البنكي بشكل ذاتي
بدون أدنى تدخل منك.
ولكن ماذا لو تطور الأمر وكان هذا المتجر
يحتوي أيضاً على تقنيات ذكية
مثل جهاز آلي لنستغني به عن الإنسان فيكون
قادر على استقبال هذا الطلب
الذي خرج من ثلاجة منزلك ويقوم بانتقاء
القطع الموجودة في رفوف هذا المتجر
يقوم بتغليفها وتسليمها لطائرة بدون طيار
ليقوم بتوصيل الطلب لمنزلك،
ويقوم بخصم القيمة النهائية من الحساب
البنكي الخاص بك
بدون أدنى تدخل من البشر في جميع مراحل
التسلسل اللتي تحدثنا عنها في هذا المثال.
ثم تتطور الأمور للخروج من أبل سيري أو
الهواتف الذكية
والخروج من نطاق البيوت الذكية وصولاً الى
المصانع الذكية،
كل جزء موجود بهذا المصنع يحتوي على جهاز
استشعار
قادر على أن يقرأ أدق التفاصيل الموجودة
ويتنبأ باحتياج الأجزاء
الموجودة في خطوط الانتاج وحاجتها الى صيانة
أو ما يسمى بنموذج الصيانة التنبؤي
التي تتنبأ باحتياج هذا الجزء من المصنع الى
الصيانة من قبل حدوث كارثة.
ولكن، ماذا لو تطور الأمر أكثر في مكونات
الثورة الصناعية المستقبلية
وتفاعل هذا المصنع مع العميل الخارجي ليقوم
بالدخول في مسمى جديد وهو سلسلة القيم،
ليكون العميل أو الإنسان جزء من عملية
التصنيع بحيث سيصنع منتجات في المستقبل
كل منتج منها خاص في كل إنسان بشكل مستقل
ومنعزل عن غيره من الأشخاص.
مثال، إذا احتجت الى قطعة أثاث أو قطعة لباس
بإمكاني أن أُرسل طلب الى المصنع
ليقوم المصنع باصدار كم هائل جداً من
الاحتمالات الذكية
اللتي تتوافق مع احتياجاتي.
ولكن، ماذا لو قام هذا المصنع بالتفاعل معي
بشكل أكثر احترافية
وقام بإرسال طلبي الذي ظهر عندي بطريقة
افتراضية لهاتفي،
واستطعت من خلال هاتفي أن أرى باستخدام
الواقع الافتراضي أو الواقع المعزز،
أن أرى تناسق وتفاعل هذا الشكل من المنتج
الذي قمت بطلبه مع البيئة المحيطة بي،
لأتأكد بأنه فعلاً المنتج الذي أريده تماماً
قبل أن أعطي الطلب النهائي للمصنع
ليقوم بإنتاج هذه القطعة.
ولكن الى ماذا يسعى العالم كمستوى أعظم من
هذا بكثير
من ناحية التطوير التقني في الثورة
الصناعية الرابعة،
الى ما يسمى بمظلة المدن الذكية،
تتفاعل مكونات البنية التحتية كلها للدولة
في المدن الذكية مع كل ما تم ذكره قبل قليل
من مصانع وبيوت ذكية وهواتف ذكية وسيارات
ذاتية القيادة،
وتتفاعل مع الأشخاص والأشياء، حتى البنية
التحتية يكون فيها جهاز استشعار لكل جزء
سواء أكان في شبكة المياه أو الكهرباء أو في
شبكة الصرف الصحي،
حيث تتفاعل كل هذه الأشياء مع بعضها البعض
وكأنها عقول بشرية ذكية
قادرة على أن تفهم لغتها المشتركة وتتواصل
بطريقة غاية في الدقة وغاية في الذكاء.
ولكن، هذا الحجم الهائل جداّ من المدخلات
الصوتية أو المرئية أو النصية
بحاجة لعقل جديد وأمكانات جديدة قادرة على
أن تستوعب هذه المادة ويتفاعل معها
وكأنه عقل بشري،
وهذا هو تماماً الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي
يتداخل مع كل مكونات ثورة المستقبل.
(صورة)
بداية تفاعل الإنسان مع ذكاء الآلة كان من
خلال الآلة الحاسبة،
اللتي تفوقت على قدرات العقل البشري من
ناحية إجراء العمليات الحسابية،
ثم تطور الأمر الى ذاكرة الحاسوب،
القادرة بقدرات متفوقة على قدرات عقلك على
أن تحفظ كم هائل جداً من البيانات
وتسترجعها بسرعة أسرع من قدرتك على
استرجاع تلك البيانات،
بالإضافة الى دقة الوصول الى البيانات
بالشكل الصحيح،
وهذا الأمر يتفوق على قدرات الإنسان.
ولكن ماذا لو قمنا بمحاولة دمج القدرات
الإدراكية التي يتميز العقل البشري بها،
ودمجناها داخل هذه الآلة، ما الذي سوف
يخرج لنا؟
بدأت ثورة الذكاء الاصطناعي وتفاعل الإنسان
معها
(صورة)
منذ أول تجربة ثورية حصلت في تسعينيات القرن
الماضي،
عندما فاز نظام IBM Deep Blue
على بطل العالم في لعبة الشطرنج
البطل الروسي كاسباروف، فكانت ردة الفعل
العظيمة من كاسباروف في لحظة معينة
خلال هذه اللعبة، عندما حاول كاسباروف أن
يضع الطُعم لنظام IBM Deep Blue
ولكن كانت المفاجأة أن النظام لم يأكل
الطُعم،
فلو قمت بوضع نفسك مكان كاسباروف أول
تساؤل سوف يخطر في بالك،
سوف تُشكك في هذه الآلة، وتقول بأن من قام
بهذه الحركة ليست بآلة
يتحكم بها نظام منطقي حسابي، وإنما شخص
يدرك ما الذي يفعله ويقف خلف هذه الآلة.
ثم تطور الأمر بشكل أكثر عمقاً وأكثر تحدياُ
لقدرات العقل البشري
في لعبة "ألفا غو" التي قام بتصميمها
DeepMind
هذه اللعبة جداً معقدة وأعقد كثيراً من
لعبة الشطرنج،
عند النظر لها بشكل سريع،
سنجد أن هذه اللعبة مكونة من 19 عموداً و 19
سطراً أي ما يساوي 361 موقع،
في كل موقع من مواقع هذه اللعبة يحتمل ثلاث
احتمالات،
مما يعني أن احتمالات المواقع مجموعة يساوي
300^361
لم يتوقف الأمر على احتمالات المواقع
وإنما احتمالات عدد حركات الأحجار داخل هذه
المواقع سيصل الى 10^768
أي ما يعادل في بعض التقديرات التي قالها
العلماء عدد ذرات الكون مجتمعةً،
والأدهى والأمر من هذا كله أن هذه اللعبة لا
تعتمد على المنطق الحسابي
وإنما تعتمد في أغلب حركاتها على الحدس،
فكانت المفاجأة في قدرة هذا النظام المتقدم
جداً
على امتلاك قدرات الحدس اللتي يمتلكها العقل
البشري،
وتفوق على بطل العالم في هذه اللعبة وفاز
عليه بها.
لو حاولنا بشكل سريع جداً أن نفهم كيف يفهم
العقل البشري
(صورة)
الصور اللتي يراها،
لو نظرنا الى وجه الإنسان، وعقله داخله يقوم
بمحاولة رؤية هذه الصورة للوجه
بأكثر من مستوى، ثم في النهاية يقوم بتجميع
المستويات مجتمعةً للخروج بنتيجة نهائية.
على سبيل المثال، في اللحظة الأولى أو في
المستوى الأول أحاول أن أرى أبعاد الوجه،
كما ترون في الصورة.
في المستوى الثاني، يحاول دماغي أن يرى
المسافات بين الأشياء،
من الممكن أن أرى المسافات بين العينين،
بين الحواجب، بين فروة الرأس والحواجب،
بين الأنف والفم.
مستوى ثالث يرى أعداد الأشياء ليتأكد من
وجود عينين اثنتين وأنف واحد وفم واحد
وأذنين اثنتين،
ومستوى أخر يمكن أن يرى الألوان،
ومستوى أخر يمكن أن يرى العمق،
ومستوى أخر يمكن أن يرى تفاصيل أكثر،
ولكن في النهاية وفي أجزاء من الثانية يقوم
الدماغ بطريقة ذكية جداً لا يمكن تفسيرها
بجمع كل هذه المستويات مع بعضها البعض،
حتى استطيع بهذه السرعة المذهلة أن أدرك
بأن هذا هو وجه إنسان،
هذا تماماً ما يقوم به الذكاء الاصطناعي،
أن يحاول فهم مكانيكية وطريقة عمل الدماغ،
وكيف تتكامل هذه المستويات مع بعضها،
وصولاُ الى مرحلة أن تتمكن الآلة من
القدرات الإدراكية للعقل البشري،
ولكن ما الذي سوف يحصل لو استطعنا من تمكين
الآلة
(صورة)
من هذا الكم الهائل جداً من هذه
القدرات الإدراكية للعقل البشري،
(صورة)
كيف سوف تتصرف الآلة كآلة ذكية؟
ولكن حتى نصل الى هذا المستوى ستحتاج الآلة
الى مرحلة من التدريب
كما احتاج الإنسان الى سنوات من التدريب،
حتى تتمكن الآلة من تشغيل نموذج ليمييز صورة
القط عن غيرها من الصور
احتاج الى تدريبه على مئات أو عشرات الألاف
من صور القطط حتى يصل الى مرحلة
هذا النموذج الاصطناعي قادر على فهم الأنماط
المشتركة بين صور القطط
لأجل غاية واحدة فقط في النهاية أن استطيع
من خلال تشغيل هذا النموذج
(صورة)
أن أميز صورة القط عن الأشياء المحيطة فيها.
أو أن أصل لمستوى أعمق في تشغيل نماذج ذكاء
اصطناعي
قادرة على أن تميز الأشياء عن الأشخاص،
أو من الممكن أكثر عمقاً أن أميز شخصيين
اثنين إذا كانا توأمين،
بنسبة دقة أعلى بكثير من قدرة العين المجردة
للإنسان على التميز بين شخصين توأمين.
ولكن ماذا لو تطور الأمر وقمنا بتشغيل
نماذج اصطناعية
قادرة على تتبع الشخص وهو يتحرك في محيط هو
موجود به،
وأميز هذا الشخص عن كل ما يدور حوله،
أو من الممكن أن يتطور الأمر من خلال نموذج
اصطناعي سريع جداً
(صورة)
قادر على أن يميز مجموعة أشخاص متحركين
ضمن نطاق وحيز معين.
أو يتطور الأمر ليصبح قادر خلال نموذج
اصطناعي واحد
(صورة)
أن أميز الأشخاص عن الأشياء بطريقة سريعة
جداً تحاكي قدرة العقل البشري،
بل أسرع وأكثر عمقاً وأقل تشتتاً،
وهذا تماماً ما يميز قدرات الذكاء
الاصطناعي.
ما الذي يحصل إذا مكنا الآلة من قدرة السمع،
(صورة)
والبصر، وفهم النصوص وتحليلها، أو قدرة
اتخاذ القرارات،
سوف يخرج لنا ابتكارات ثورية تغير العالم،
هذه الابتكارات فعلاً هي مكونات ثورة
المستقبل، الثورة الصناعية الرابعة،
من المؤكد أن البعض قد سمع عن ابتكارات
حديثة لأنظمة الذكاء الاصطناعي،
(صورة)
قادرة من خلال تحليل كم كبير جداً من الصور
المخبرية،
أن تكشف عن احتمالية وجود السرطان في هذا
الشخص،
أو ابتكارات لمساعدتنا، ولقد لوحظ أنها قامت
بثورة في حجم الخدمات المقدمة لنا،
مثل أبل سيري أو مساعد غوغل أو أمازون
أليكسا،
أو مثلاً آلة التصوير في الهواتف الذكية،
فهي تحتوي على آلة تصوير متقدمة جداً،
وتمتلك امكانيات الذكاء الاصطناعي فبمجرد أن
أوجه آلة التصوير باتجاه شيء معين
لأقوم بتصويره، يستطيع نظام الذكاء
الاصطناعي،
المتواجد داخل الهاتف أن يعرف الشيء قبل أن
يقوم بتصويره،
بمعنى أن آلة التصوير قادرة على معرفة أن
هذا صحن فاكهة،
فتقوم بتعديل الوضوح بما يتناسب مع صحن
الفاكهة،
أو أن آلة التصوير قادرة على معرفة أن هذه
سيارة،
فتقوم بتعديل الوضوح بما يتناسب مع معرفتها
للشيء الذي تراه،
أو مثلاً في السيارات ذاتية القيادة،
اللتي يعول العالم عليها كثيراً في المستقبل
لتخفيض نسبة حوادث السير المتوقعة،
أو هناك شيء ثوري جداً سوف يصيبكم في
الذهول،
الطبيبة النفسية الافتراضية إلي،
(صورة)
يمكنك أن تتواصل معها ولقد تم تزويدها
بشيئيين رئيسيين،
ولأجل ذلك تفوقت الطبيبة النفسية إلي على
مجمل الأطباء النفسيين المتواجدين في العالم
لو استمر تطويرها على هذا النهج.
أول شيءٍ تم تزويدها بكل ما انتجته البشرية
من علم الطب النفسي والأبحاث
والدراسات في هذا المجال،
والشيء الثاني أنه تم تزويدها بأغلب النماذج
العقلية الإدراكية،
لدرجة أن الطبيبة الافتراضية إلي قادرة من
خلال آلات التصوير والحساسات والمذياع
اللتي تنظر الى وجه المريض الذي يبحث عن
الاستشارة النفسية،
أن تقوم بتحديد أدق التفاصيل في وجهه وصولاً
الى توسع أو تضييق حدقة العين،
بشكل أكثر عمقاً وأكثر دقةً من الانتباه
الذي من الممكن أن يصل له الطبيب النفسي
بالعين المجردة.
كيف من الممكن أن نقول بأن الذكاء الاصطناعي
(صورة)
سوف يصنع ثورة اصطناعية جديدة؟
ما يميز العقل البشري عن غيره من الأنظمة
الاصطناعية
هو ذلك الصندوق الأسود الذي يصعب تفسيره.
ما المقصود بهذا الصندوق الأسود؟
هو القدرة على الحدس وليس فقط القدرة على
النظر أو السمع أو فهم النص
أو فهم الكلام المحكي،
القدرة على الحدس اللتي تستطيع بإمكانها أن
تقوم بترابط
بين عدد ضخم جداً من النماذج الإدراكية
المتواجدة في عقلك،
للوصول لنتيجة لن يحتاج عقلك لتفسيرها،
لو قام بتفسيرها ستتأخر وستحدث الكارثة.
تخيل لو كنت على وشك السقوط في حفرة،
لو سوف يفسر دماغك كل ما يقوم بتحليله خلال
عملية الحدس أو خلال عملية الإدراك،
سوف تسقط في الحفرة قبل حدوث ردة الفعل
المطلوبة.
لنأخذ هذا المثال الأخير،
أحمد خرج من دوامه وكان غاضباً،
(صورة)
وحدث سوء تفاهم بينه وبين مديره،
فقام أحمد بكتابة إيميل أخير وأرسله لمديره،
فقام نظام مركزي بتحليل هذا النص الموجود
في البريد،
واستطاع فهم من خلال تحليل النص، بأن أحمد
كان حزيناً وغاضباً،
وعنما خرج أحمد لسيارته وهو متوجه لمنزله،
نظر لهاتفه ليرى الوقت، أو الى ساعته الذكية
اللتي تحتوي على آلة تصوير،
استطاعت هذه آلة التصوير أن تكشف تفاصيل وجه
أحمد،
لتتأكد من تعابير وجهه "الأردنية"، أنه كان
غاضباً جداً وحزين،
وعندما كان متوجه لمنزله جاءه اتصالٌ هاتفي،
استطاع المذياع المتواجد في هاتفه، أن يتأكد
من خلال نبرة صوت أحمد بدقة أكثر بكثير،
بأن نبرة صوت أحمد توحي فعلاً بأنه حزين
وغاضب،
وفي اللحظة الأخيرة قبل دخوله الى منزله،
فتح على موقع الفيسبوك، كما نفعل نحن دائماً
لنفضفض بكل مشاعرنا وأحاسيسنا هناك،
فقام ذلك النظام المركزي بتحليل البريد
الإلكتروني له، وصورته وصوته
وأيضاً المنشور اللتي كتبها على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي،
في نظام مركزي واحد لأجل ماذا؟
لأجل تقديم خدمة رفاهية مستقبلية، قد يظن
البعض بأنها خدمة ساذجة وسهلة،
ولكن الموضوع أعظم من ذلك بكثير،
من الممكن مع دخول أحمد لمنزله أن يقوم هذا
النظام المركزي بتشغيل موسيقى له
لتهدأ من أحمد وتريحه.
من الممكن أن يصل المموضوع لأبعد من هذا
بكثير،
من الممكن أن يرسل اشعار بشكل تلقائي لزوجته
يقول لها توخي الحذر،
لا تتكلمي معه فهو مضغوط.
(ضحك)
وأظن بأن هذا هو أعظم ما يمكن أن ينتجه
الذكاء الاصطناعي.
(ضحك)
(تصفيق)
أظن أن الأمر يتجاوز هذه الأمور لمستويات
أعمق بكثير،
الشركات العالمية تستثمر بالمليارات بهذا
الأمر لغايات أمور أخرى
سوف تستفيد منها من الناحية المادية،
في اللحظة اللتي من الممكن أن استغل مشاعر
أحمد،
كشركة منتجة لعدد ضخم جداً من المنتجات،
استطيع أن ارسل له اشعار في تلك اللحظة
عن منتج أنا متأكد تماماً بأن أحمد سوف
يقوم بشرائه.
أو من الممكن أن أقوم بتجميع هذا الكم
الهائل جداً من البيانات عن أحمد
في نظام مركزي وأقارن ما بينه وبين الأشخاص
المتواجدين حول العالم
الذين يشتركون معه بنفس النمط وبنفس طريقة
التفكير للخروج بتقنيات ثورية
سوف تغير المستقبل وسوف تغير العالم.
كل ذلك هو ما اسميته بتفاعل الأشياء ضمن
عالم انترنت الأشياء
(صورة)
ولكن أين الذكاء الاصطناعي بالضبط في هذه
الرحلة الطويلة؟
الذكاء الاصطناعي يتداخل في ثلاث مستويات
أساسية، في المستوى الأول:
في طريقة فهم النصوص أو الصور أو الكلام
المحكي وادراكه وكأنه عقل بشري.
في المستوى الثاني في محاولة عملية تحليل
هذه البيانات وادراكها
ومعرفة الأنماط الموجودة فيها،
وكلما زاد تدريب هذه النماذج كلما وصلنا
لمرحلة في الاقتراب الى نسبة دقة من 100%.
والمستوى الثالث في اتخاذ القرار تماماً كما
قامت سيري بالتكلم معك،
وقالت لك بأنه قد تم حجز موعدك الذي قمت
بطلبه مع طبيبك في التاريخ ذلك.
هكذا تتفاعل الأمور مع بعضها البعض،
وهكذا سوف يصنع الذكاء الاصطناعي مستقبل
العالم.
مشكلتنا في عوالمنا هذه أننا نتعامل مع
الذكاء الاصطناعي ومع ثورة المستقبل
كمستخدمين لها ولسنا كصانعين للتقنية.
أعتقد بأن المصادر مفتوحة أو غير مفتوحة
المصدر الكثيرة المتاحة الآن على الانترنت،
وأيضاً في النماذج الادراكية المدربة مسبقاً
كالقدرة على فهم الأشياء وادراكها،
مثل القدرة على تميز الأشخاص عن الأشياء،
جميعها الآن متواجدة على الانترنت ومتاحة
للجميع،
ما عليك الا أن تأتي بهذه النماذج الادراكية
الصناعية،
ثم تضيفها الى أي شيء موجود حولك،
لتصنع منتجات فورية سوف تغيير العالم،
وسوف تغيير المجتمع الذي نعيش به،
لكي نكون جزء من هذه الثورة ولسنا فقط
مستخدمين لها.
شكراً لكم.
(تصفيق)